I had a friend at one point who was a
very bitter person and he had a bunch of
problems and some of them were self
inflicted in some of them were fate I
suppose,
and he had his.
He had become very,
very destructive,
murderously,
destructive,
genocidally destructive.
I would say.
You could see it in his dreams and,
and he lived with me for awhile and I
knew him very well.
He was a friend of mine from the time I
was 12 until the time he committed
suicide when he was 40 and when he lived
with me I was trying to help him get on
his feet,
which was why he had come to live with
me because he thought maybe I could help
him get on his feet and he could only
take relatively low level jobs.
You know,
like he had some mechanical ability.
He didn't,
he didn't get educated.
Although he's a very,
very smart person.
He probably had an Iq of about 135 or
something like that.
He's very smart and so he was bitter too
because he hadn't educated themselves to
the level that has,
as you know,
his intellect would have demanded.
So we had to take jobs that were beneath
him intellectually and he had a re.
He had that real intellectual arrogance,
you know,
because he was smart and really smart
people often come to believe that only
smart matters and if they're smart and
all that and all that matters is smart
and then the world is sort of laying
itself at their feet and they've been
terribly betrayed and,
and then they claim to their
intelligence which is more like a talent
or a gift.
Like it's like it's an idol,
you know,
a false idol,
which is exactly what it is in a very
dangerous one.
And get cynical about the stupidity of
the world and the fact that there are
talents weren't properly recognized and
that's just not that helpful because
smart is a good thing.
But I'll tell you,
if you don't use it properly,
it will devour you just like all
arbitrarily assigned.
Tell it right.
So you might have a talent,
but it's your friend.
If you use it properly and you misuse
it,
it will be your enemy and maybe that's
how God keeps the cosmic scales
adjusted.
But anyhow,
my friend was a very smart person,
although not as smart as he thought he
was unfortunately and and,
but he hadn't done what would have been
necessary with that intelligence to make
it manifest itself properly in the
world.
And that also embittered him because he
also knew that there was more that he
could have done if he would have done it
and perhaps more that he could still do
what I was suggesting to him while he
was living with us because he was,
you know,
two levels from homeless by that point
was that he should find a job that he
could find working in a garage,
working in a shop,
something like that because he had some
mechanical ability and that he should
do.
He should separate himself from the
arrogance that made him presumed that
such a job would be beneath him because
at that point no job was beneath him.
And,
but more importantly,
it's not so obvious that jobs are
beneath people,
you know.
Because even if you're a,
even if you imagine you have a job as a
checkout person in a grocery store,
you know as a fairly unskilled job,
you can be in some miserable,
resentful,
horrid bastard doing that job.
Boy,
you know you can come in there just
exuding resentment and bitterness and
making mistakes and making sure that
every customer that passes by you has a
slightly worse day than they need to
write and pilfering time and perhaps
pilfering goods and being resentful
about the people who,
who gave you the position because
they're above you in the dominance
hierarchy and talking bad things.